Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie. Today's video
is going to be all about Ser Jorah and Azor
Ahai. So just careful for spoilers for everything
this happen through season 6 so far. You may
have heard about the idea that Ser Jorah is
secretly Azor Ahai he is the one who was promised
he will come back reborn. this new hero to
end the next long night. I don't think that's
the case I think the real twist with Azor
Ahai is going to be something different, but
Ser Jorah is still very important to that
so because there's so much craziness happening
this weekend and George RR Martin just confirmed
that he's going to be including some new Targaryen
chapters in that book this fall, there's a
new round of the game of thrones giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's for
one of the enhanced editions of the books.
So the last time we saw Ser Jorah Daenerys
gave him a very important thing to do. You
have one thing to do. Find your self a cure
then return to me is a very emotional scene
will likely do not look away from your clean
Jorah the Andal not be dismissed he takes
just have to make he's watch what they might
come onto the rest of your life like a mantra
to find fictional every citizen is well. I
can lunge you to heal yourself and then attend
the take the 7 kingdoms need to Primus
is sad is that moment is you want a big win
for Ser Jorah down the road. He's not dead
yet. It's important foreshadowing for the
future. So what is he going to do he's going
to seek out a cure at the rate that grayscale's
progressing he could make it through the last
two seasons he be okay he be a little crazy
by the end, but he'd still be there. That
mission the course that is going to set him
on is where we get wrapped up in the is or
high plot line there's this runner that there's
going to be a revelation of someone who is
the song of ice and fire who will save us
from the long night this mythical leader who
was the prince that was promised. Most people
believe that is Jon Snow there couple alternative
theories, but the big twist is going to be
something a little bit different. I think
the gonna try to flip your heads on it because
all the cast members of and say oh it's gonna
blow your mind you will be prepared for it.
So it's not gonna be some simple answer, but
even if Jura is not as or high himself, the
reason he's very important to this theory
is is because as he seeking a cure there only
a couple of places in the world that you can
go to get that there are many centers of learning
and knowledge in the East the shy the place
were Mela Sandro comes from the place where
Daenerys's Dragon eggs came from is is really
crazy place where a lot of people study via
cold shadow binders people with abilities
like Mela Sandro hopefully the show goes there
at some point but I don't think we'll ever
actually get to it during the main series
red priests themselves also have crazy healing
abilities but usually it comes at great cost
in the books sectarians can get poisoned in
the act of healing. It almost involves burning
it off outright. So imagine surge or having
to burn his hand off just to cure the grayscale,
but the other place Jura could go to in the
more logical place would be the Citadel if
you remember, Stannis was talking about how
Shareen got grayscale and he brought all of
the finest maced her's is fast as possible
they were able to stop the disease before
progress any further cooled in every minister
on the side of the world every Gila every
up the stuff. The disease in cinchona. So
right now the Citadel is the greatest center
of knowledge that you could go to there probably
a lot of other people in the East, but for
the most part, the show is done with the East.
I think will still see some scenes in the
East for context, but everyone is converging
on west roast and that would mean that if
Ser Jorah if this foreshadowing lives up to
its promise will meet Daenerys as she starts
to take the 7 kingdoms before that he has
to heal himself. Meaning that he would likely
go to the Citadel and who else is at the Citadel,
but Sam well because there only 7 episodes
instead of 10 you have to imagine that there's
going to be this increased economy of narrative
where they try to cram in as much exposition
plot development character development into
a small of space as possible, which means
fewer characters in accomplishing a number
of goals in the same moment with the same
ideas. Sam well went to the Citadel to become
a maced her and to learn things that would
help them in their fight against the white
walkers meeting learning how to re-forge valyrian
steel may be learning some things about Jon
snows parentage that would help them when
it comes time to face Daenerys and her army
thinking about the convergence of characters.
Now if Ser Jorah were to come to the Citadel
looking for a cure for grayscale he would
eventually run into Sam well and it's very
convenient for them to align those characters
whereby Sam well help Ser Jorah find a way
to cure his grayscale and then they both go
their respective ways until they meet again
when Daenerys finally meets with the forces
of the North. So you have someone on each
side who has some information it's very important
to the plot. This is who Jon Snow really is.
This is how we fight white walkers we need
a lot of the resources that you have. We need
your manpower. We need alliance and look what
else we learn, there's this common thread
binding you by blood. So there just so many
reasons why we should team up so you have
Ser Jorah telling this to Daenerys and her
forces you have Sam well telling this to Jon
Snow and his forces. So the each sort of learned
information at the same pace we also have
to address the importance of bran when it
comes to conveying information. Sort of a
WTF guy who shows up and says there's this
crazy ship is going down and guess what your
father was secretly a Targaryen, so you could
tell that the Jon snow and he might believe
that he might not believe it, but the rest
of the people of the rest of the Lords of
the North. The other forces that they're going
to have to be working with will need some
proof and that's where you get to Ser Jorah
and Sam well because bran is Mr. prophecy,
but prophecy is one thing most people say
prophecy be damned. So you have to have some
concrete evidence to present people with in
where would you find stuff like that in the
Citadel so Daenerys could learn the Jon snow
as her blood the dragons could even have an
affinity for him, but unless someone vouches
for Jon Snow that she trusts like Ser Jorah
it looks like after that moment, that they
shared together she trusts him more than anyone
else, even though that wasn't always the case.
It just seems like she loves him so if he
were to tell her something she would be more
likely to believe it. The Lords of the North
like the little bear or even more stubborn
you're going to have to give them some concrete
proof. So Sam well with all his books, scrolls
evidence from the Citadel is capable of doing
that. So even though Ser Jorah might not be
Azor Ahai himself he still very critical piece
of that puzzle Ser Jorah instrument of prophecy
critical to the coming together of these two
big forces you can see how you with this convergence
of narrative in the economy of narrative Heather
taking really big characters that you care
about really big callbacks to moments in previous
seasons and conveying really important plot
points through them. The really important
parts of this are in learning Jon Snow's true
heritage finding evidence of that Jura curing
his grayscale and Sam well learning about
the importance of Dragon glass you remember
the offhanded way that the show started teasing
that radar Targaryen might not be the person
that everyone made him out to be that Robert
made him out to be the beginning of the series
she should be on the hills. So, what the.
So the clouds above is my sister switch ship
along with me in my dreams it's done is Targaryens
agon the whole show wants to boy from each
other's family thought wench had a great tone
and how and how when Ray go on. Everyone shares
for the Prince to Lee Road I post his wife
him not smiles died in a a crown of winter
roses and the on his lap how many tens of
thousands to die because Rhaegar chose your
aunt yes he chose kidnapped
you hear Robert's comment everything that
you see tells you that he is the hero of the
story. But then you get this really big bomb
dropped in an offhanded remark. Maybe the
things that you believed were true, this is
where the big twist with Azor Ahai comes in.
So the idea that it's not any one person even
radar himself as we learn from little finger
was not a bad guy from barest and sell me
who told really funny stories about him he
took the strict letter of the prophecy that
it would be a child of his of Prince who was
promised, it's a valyrian prophecy in high
valyrian is gender-neutral. So the big twist.
I think that is that it's going to be two
people to nurse and Jon Snow. Not just one
as or high figure, so let me know how do you
think that Ser Jorah is going to figure into
the revelation of all this important information
in season 7 and I'll say congratulations to
the new giveaway winner Eddie Lindsay please
private message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details. There was
a new round that started in this video I'll
announce the winner the next time I post a
game of thrones video. Please leave all your
request for bonus videos in the comments below,
because it Super Bowl weekend I'll be posting
a bunch of trailers later tonight so the be
links coming out through the rest of the day
while you wait for that you can click here
for more game of thrones season 7 videos and
you can click here for more Super Bowl trailers.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you in the next video!